[Music]
jackson
is with us in utah hi jackson welcome to
the dave ramsey show
thank you uh i just want to first say
thank you for your show i've been
listening for about a month now and i
absolutely love it well thanks
how can we help so just uh just a little
background i'm 19 years old
i have 23 000 in the bank with a 16 000
auto loan that i have a two year plan
paid off um
so i leave to basic training in a week
from today
and when i get back i have i plan to
have thirty thousand dollars before i go
to school again
in the fall and so my question is
should i invest in a roth ira
right now or should i get that car paid
off
when you go to school in the fall uh is
the military paying for it
yeah so i'll get my tuition paid for 100
cool
good for you yes so which branch are you
going into jackson
uh the army national guard okay good for
you that's a good program they've got
um we've been sponsored by them and been
bragging on them for many years they're
just wonderful
it's a wonderful program you're doing
write a check and pay off your car today
and pay it off today
kind of put your stomach in your throat
a little bit jackson
yeah it does a little bit but yeah well
you got a pretty expensive car for this
situation
you could consider moving down in car
because you're a college student with a
sixteen thousand dollar car
yeah and uh the good news is your
college is paid for are you getting a
stipend as well
yeah how much yeah so we're not
expecting but i will i do get the
benefits from the guy which
comes out to almost a thousand dollars a
month okay if that's what you're asking
and uh are you living on campus or at
home
uh so i just barely moved home from
college but in the fall
or in the summer i'll be living in
student housing
after basic training okay but in the
this coming fall you said you're going
to school right
yeah and you will be on campus then
yeah is that paid for plus a thousand
dollars or you need the thousand dollars
to pay for that
no it's the tuition paid for plus a
thousand dollars
now what about the housing no
i'll be saying out of the thousand
dollars
yes okay so what i'm trying to figure
out is if you pay off that car today are
you gonna have enough
money to go to school in the fall and
pay your bills
um yeah i plan to i have a
job right now pay 17 an hour so i find
to work
um part-time for 20 hours a week
even while you're in school okay okay
yeah that's wonderful yeah that is all
right so if you can i want you to go
back and check my numbers okay but i
think i'm understanding you
with the tuition paid for and the
thousand dollar stipend and the 17
plus you've got uh seven thousand
dollars left over
and you said you'd have 30 by the time
you get back home so that's another
seven
so you'd have 14 in there i just want
you to be able to go to school with zero
debt
and no car payment and be able to eat if
you can do all of that i want you to pay
off your car today
if you cannot do all of that i want you
to sell your car and move down in car
and pay cash for the car that allows you
to do that one of those two things i
think you can pull it off
yeah if i've understood your numbers
correctly in this conversation i think
you can pull it off
now and and dave you point out the point
of understanding that's too much car for
that
for his income well in his situation
he's a college student right
and he's and he's forward thinking i
mean number one to be 19 and have 23 000
saved in an accident uh that's a big
deal and so great job there
yes 16 000 alone not so great
not so good right yeah so it's like the
happy hogan zad hogan
you know you don't want to do that but
buddy to
stroke that check if you run the numbers
oh my friend
you'll be settling that's an emoji right
it is an emoji it really is
happy hogan's sad hogan emojis at least
a meme yeah at least
we got and speaking of if you've not
checked out the chris hogan show i want
you to check it out
um uh get over there speaking of that i
am notorious for facial gestures and
expressions
they've got gifs and things set up on
the team shows during the show
but we have a lot of fun uh the chris
hogan show check it out you can find it
on youtube apple podcast google all the
things
uh we have a lot of fun it's color
driven as well and we do some segments
called
panicked or pumped did we get to see
happy hogan yes we do
we do and dave i've got a flag that i
throw on people who are doing stupid
i'll show you like i throw up like a
football throwback
throw a penalty flag on them football
throwbacks right but you gotta come
check it out are you wearing your little
referee mask no they take it on and off
so much they might
not be wearing it it's so frustrating to
me that's so hilarious it is
it really is